Structural queries are still a
big need for modern web apps.
And with Web SQL deprecated,
IndexedDB not having
structural queries,
web developers
need a tool to satisfy their
structural query needs.
Hi.
My name is Arthur
Hsu, and I'm here
to talk about the
Lovefield project that
solves the problem.
Lovefield is a relational
database for web apps.
Web app developers
need structural queries
that work in the mobile world.
Our users need the web app to
work either online or offline.
How can we build such apps?
This seems to be the
reason IndexedDB was built.
But even with offline support,
there is a steep learning curve
to make it useful for your app.
Moreover, IndexedDB does not
provide structural queries,
so many of us just write domain
specific query functions that
works only for the apps
that we were working on.
To address these problems, I
built Lovefield, a JavaScript
driven relational database
that runs inside your browser.
Lovefield improves on
the concept of IndexedDB
with simpler APIs
and more control
over persistent storage.
It is build for
structural query needs.
IndexedDB does not offer
structural query features
such as sorting by
multiple columns
or joining the results
of multiple tables.
These can be easy
done with Lovefield.
Lovefield also makes
data persistence way
easier in two ways.
First, the APIs are
much easier to use.
And secondly, Lovefield
offers transactions
which provide you full
control on when to flush data
to persistent stores.
The last and most
important part is
Lovefield is designed
with developers in mind.
It is open source, easy to use,
cross browser-- yes you hear me
correctly.
Lovefield works on IE,
Chrome, Firefox, and Safari.
Even better,
Lovefield is designed
to work with existing
JavaScript frameworks.
And we've tested with
jQuery, Angular, and Polymer
with no problem.
Let's move to a quick example
to see what Lovefield can do.
Assume we have two
different type of objects.
One is called Task that
stores a task to be finished.
And the other is called
Person which stores
data about a person in our app.
In the good old days,
we list all tasks
that are in the works
with their owners
using this simple SQL statement.
Select from task
and person where
task state equals to working and
task owner equals to person.id.
How shall we do this shiny
new JavaScript web app?
Let's forget about the code
that reads data out of index db.
Let's just concentrate
on the select logic.
Say we have an array of tasks
objects, a hash table that maps
person ID to person objects.
To do the select, we
need this wall code.
This code's problem
is not only the size,
but also how much effort needed
to maintain or change it.
Lovefield is designed to make
the simple SELECT simple again.
In Lovefield, we describe
data type of table in schema
To construct a query, we
first retrieve the schema
by calling the getSchema
function of the database
connection.
Then we construct our query
using the builder pattern,
which is very similar
to SQL SELECT statement
and easy to learn.
Lovefield's queries are
JavaScript functions.
After minifying
and uglifying, it
makes SQL injection
next to impossible.
This is very good
for security reasons.
It also has positive
impacts on performance.
You're writing
JavaScript functions
that cascade together.
There's no need for a SQL
parser, and it just works.
Lovefield can do more
than just simple queries.
It has some great
functionality such as grew by,
event sorting, pagination using
LIMIT and SKIP, and so on.
The code snippet
here demonstrates how
to group results, sort the
results by multiple columns,
and implement pagination
using LIMIT and SKIP.
Lovefield's relational
query engine
provides SQL-like functions--
fundamental functions, SELECT,
INSERT, UPDATE, and DELETE,
and also atomic transactions
that you have to control
to commit or roll back.
I've shown events sorting,
LIMIT, and SKIP, and GROUP
BY in previous slides.
Moreover, Lovefield has common
aggregators, inner table join,
self table join, left
outer join, and aliases.
These features empower you to
perform very complex queries
in very few lines of code.
Lovefield provides
parameterized queries.
And the idea is
to prepare a query
and bind the variables
to that query
so that the runtime values
of the bound variables
will be used to run the query.
One super cool
feature that Lovefield
has is observable query.
Lovefield allows observation of
the results of a SELECT query.
Say another
asynchronous function
in the code updates
table of contents
or the values of the
parameterized query findings
change.
The updated query results
will be propagated
to the handler of the observer.
This offers a clean way
of updating UI contents
in an event driven fashion.
Behavior wise, Lovefield has
integrity constraint checks,
B+-Tree for indices, a query
optimizer to ensure that
the best indices are used and
the queries are run as fast
as possible, a query analyzer
to display to the user how
the query is executed so
that developers can tune
their database and queries.
Lovefield is all
about performance.
The team created a
performance dashboard
to detail any performance
regressions for daily changes.
A lot of time has spent on
optimizing the query engine.
If you do find any
query or execution
pass that seems to be
slower than expected,
please report on GitHub,
and someone in the team
will look into it.
Lovefield makes persisting data
inside the browser much easier.
Persisting data
inside the browser
is useful when the user
go offline and want
to use the app, or to
improve the app loading
experience by using local cache
before the server data returns.
Lovefield by default
uses IndexedDB
as persistent storage.
If you're only interested in
using Lovefield's query engine
but not really wanted to
persist sensitive data
inside the browser, then
Memory DB is for you.
Lovefield cab be used as
a pure in memory cache.
Data come from some
database sources--
say service in the
cloud-- and the app
uses Lovefield's query engine to
store the least data in memory
and performs query locally.
Another exciting data
persistence layer Lovefield
has is based on Firebase.
Firebase is a cloud
based database.
Using Lovefield on top of it
makes the best of both worlds,
a fully synchronized
cloud database
and the powerful relational
query engine running on browser
provided Lovefield.
So if your web app is looking
for a simpler relational
database with the
power of SQL, Lovefield
is a perfect match for you.
For more information, check out
web based code lab from Google
I/O, or browse over to out
GitHub page and grab the code
and play around.
Feel free to leave
us some feedback.
And if you find a
problem, we're more than
happy to accept contributions.
Anyhow, check out the
Lovefield project,
and thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]